my mom just tell me god never gives you
anything
more than you can handle
well i can't handle it anymore
all right tiffany tiffany uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um i was born in king new hampshire and
i was
stayed there probably till i was in the
third grade
then my mom decided we were gonna go to
tennessee that was
just for like a year it took me back to
new hampshire
then from there i stayed there for like
not even half a year in sixth grade
we went to connecticut and i stayed in
connecticut from
fifth grade all the way up until i was
19 almost 20 years old i had my daughter
when i was 18 on my 18th birthday
actually
and i was a really raging alcoholic at
that point
after i had her i started drinking
heavily before that i just smoked pot
and one day i decided i was gonna go get
cigarettes
and my mom let me take her car and as
soon as i left the driveway she called
the cops
and told them that i was driving drunk
so i got arrested for the first time
at 19 years old and from there it just
turned into
a whole bunch of arrests for underage
drinking
retail theft um
now i have a sale of heroin charge that
i just got from california
which i didn't even sell the heroin i
gave the person the hair when they
passed it off somebody else and i got
the market money
so i was arrested for that back to your
childhood how would you describe your
childhood
horrible my mom had seven kids
which i'm the only girl out of seven
boys six boys and me
i'm the only one she kept and raised
which i don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing
they all resent me for that like all
your mommy's babies she only kept you
blah blah blah
and really and they're the lucky ones i
think i mean i love my mom today i don't
get me wrong she's my best friend
i haven't seen her for almost two years
now or my two
kids in there in new hampshire once with
their father which is my son christian
he was born in 2012 so he's going on he
just turned eight
right it's gonna turn eight something
like that i do so many drugs remember
where were your kids in new hampshire
my son's with his father and my daughter
is my mom
they live very close to each other like
from 9 to 20 minutes away
when i went to jail in vermont for like
a year
is when my mom gave her son and my
brother
and then for my brother he went to his
father and so back to your childhood
again
um any abuse any kind of crazy
things going on in your childhood my mom
never spanked me this i didn't have much
abuse from my parents
or parent because my father was never
around he's a loser he doesn't
i don't think he even knows my name half
the time he just said my brother timmy
which was like his golden angel whatever
timmy want timmy got
um when my mom got with her husband
david when we moved to connecticut which
was my stepfather to this day they're
still married
they're not together but they're so
married he
come to find out was a cocaine addict
and a raging alcoholic he'd go to the
strip club almost every single night
and when they came home and decided that
he was going to come into my room and
try to make out with me and
all your mother's sleep in wanting to
get freaky type [ __ ]
and i booked out i told my mom and she
told me i was a liar
until like in the house religion was
two-story house but i had like these
little vents in the top of the ceiling
for the heat to go upstairs
i guess she was listening to the people
one day it was event one night
and she heard it herself him talking
about my friend molly's breast and
how like just derogatory [ __ ] and she
came running down and freaked out about
it it was
little never left him she still stayed
with him
they only got separated because he went
to jeff for seven years for
manslaughter because he owned a business
and he had dump trucks and the dump
truck crashed into
it's call it's on news like the cameras
followed us around like
crazy tv stuff um if you look at avon
mountain david wilcox from windsor
connecticut
a whole bunch of [ __ ] pops up there's a
book written about it everything the
dump truck
went past the job site and went down
avon mountain and crashed into
the intersection killing five people
including himself so my stepfather went
to jail for the manslaughter
because the guy died that was driving
the dump truck obviously
and there's like a whole insurance fraud
case and everything which they won that
my mom got a big settlement so she
bought the trailer that she lives in now
so she started dating this guy named
carl morris which
was something that she did in the past
he just died in december god rest his
soul
[Music]
um my mom
decided when i started drinking i was
dating this guy named will
and he got me into snort and vicodin
percocets which is where i got
introduced to opiates or anything like
that because i was just pothead
and blood drunk too my mom
she can't pick me up one day and she
went to the store and i
saw his papers in her door and i looked
at him and there people said her taking
my daughter away from her taking me to
court and take my daughter away from me
which she went by my back and did
because we made an agreement that
she would be with me from 7 to 4 30 or
maybe 5 30 during the day and she'd go
home to my mom and night where she had
her bed and all the stuff that she
should have as a little girl
and my mom just did some she was
vindictive i think she's trying to make
up for
the parenting lack of parenting that she
did
with her grandchildren she like i've
even caught her call my daughter her
daughter
which is really weird but
that's what started my mom and my
relationship destroyed and started
destroying it
because she's trying to take so she did
take she's not trying to but she wanted
nothing to do with my son really
because of course he's a boy for some
reason she got rid of all them
um so today you're living where in a
tent
on maple street on schedule yep
yep that's where i am i just had a baby
on august or april 20th
which the state took because he had
drugs in the system
you had a baby a month ago yeah
what's your drug i smoke fentanyl and
smoke crack
i was shooting heroin but i stopped
doing that so i don't i haven't used a
needle normally here which i'm very
proud to say that
which i'm smoking fennel which is
tenders worse
i guess it's just um me running away
from my feelings really
do you look at your childhood and all
the turmoil that you went through
yeah just kind of leading you down here
yeah
well i go with my daughter's father
when i was 16 or 17 something like that
and he told me one day he was going to
get me pregnant so i was stuck with him
and i got pregnant at 17 had my daughter
on my 18th birthday
we proceeded to move from connecticut to
new hampshire in our own apartment
and my mom eventually followed she moved
to new hampshire also
um one night he decided he was going to
hit me so i called the cops got a
restraining order and i've never seen
him again since
well actually i saw my burger king once
when i was pregnant with my son in 2012
which is really awkward he's married now
he says my daughter's not his when she
looks just like his other daughter
but he doesn't deny her he just denies
mine when he knows for a fact that she
says
he just doesn't want to pay the child
support
so then
i got pregnant with my son i met his
father in florida
when i went there to visit and i got
pregnant with him
i had him in 2012. then his father
decided one day he's gonna tell me he
wasn't in love with me anymore
and at that point i didn't give a [ __ ]
anymore that's when
i gave up excuse me
i started um snorting heroin
i was just not in percocet which is how
it all started because like i said i met
will and i started starting
a vacant with him i had an ear infection
that night and he's he's like oh give me
one of those and
i didn't understand why until i did it
and i upgraded and then i upgraded even
more to needles
i left both of my kids
and when i came out here i was dating
this guy in connecticut which is a drug
dealer
which pretty much all the guys that i've
been with ever since my father's son's
mother left me here i have been drug
dealers
i was in a wicked abusive relationship
in vermont after
my son's father and me split up
um the first time the guy hit me
was in newark new jersey where we he we
went
to visit his family and we haven't been
stuck there for a few months
because in all reality he was running
away from the drugstore that he owed
money to
and i just picked up everything and went
with him like an idiot and he decided
that he was going to hit me so when he
was sleeping i left and i went to the
bus station and i went back to vermont
and three months later he shows up in
vermont and
like a dumbass i went and met him and as
soon as he closed the door he started
choking me
and told me to get in the bathroom and
take what
i say and i pretty much just get in the
bathroom
i was in the bathroom with him he beat
me for 25 minutes straight
he made me clean up the blood and if i
didn't do it right he hit me harder
he took a wooden brush and beat me in my
hands with it my ears were like big like
a boxer like when they get [ __ ] up
ears my face was totally [ __ ] up
eventually i got away from him because
he got arrested i think he's still in
jail now to this day actually
and then i started dating this other guy
and they called him bs that was his drug
dealer name
um then we did they decided they would
come to california
to spend some of the money that they've
been making selling crack
and i came with him i got lucky because
i had an expired id
and a birth certificate but they
actually let me get on the airplane
and since i was so addicted to opiates
we
originally i was supposed to quit doing
opiates a week before we left so i
didn't come here no drugs and i wasn't
sick or anything like that
that didn't happen of course so when he
was sleeping one morning
i took twenty dollars and i went outside
and asked somebody where i got drugs
they told me go six blocks that way
because i was on six and flower at the
standard until you hit san julian
it was more like 10 blocks they lied and
i came down here
i didn't know that they called it black
because we call it down where i'm from
and we call crack hard they call it
cavi here so everything was really
different i never saw crystal meth in my
life until i came here
which i don't do that drug i was
shooting fentanyl back into my overdose
four times
but when i came here i was scared to do
the fentanyl because i didn't want to
die again
and then after i stopped using needles
because i couldn't hit myself anymore my
veins were just totally
destroyed i started smoking the fentanyl
which was just an easier high a quicker
high
a better high a lot more expensive high
and i was prostitute here
i spent probably last year prostituting
to get my
drugs then i met this guy named walter
and i started working with him at the
stand that he sells when he started
selling the mask we were making like ten
thousand dollars a day selling them
things when they first started selling
and i moved in with him he was pretty
much a sugar daddy as you could call it
he wanted to marry me and have a baby
and all this crazy crap
and one night i sold two thousand
dollars cash for him
and i left and
he had me arrested he still talks to me
to his day
tells me it hurt him more to lose me
that did the money
he was a great guy actually
um and then do you have a hard time
accepting somebody who's
you would call a great guy for some
reason i do i run from love
i run from the people that want to treat
me good and i chase after the [ __ ]
that beat me
i don't understand why i think it's been
watching my mom grow when i was growing
up
she was married to this guy named he
used to be her
and there's something in my head because
that's okay which i know it's not i know
right from wrong
but for some reason i just deal with it
it's like the guy with now
i hit he was great for like the first
month
and decided he was gonna backhand me the
other day that's 11 left
it's like intellectually you understand
the one guy would be better for your
life than the other right
but your behavior just takes you there's
this guy named
here we're really good friends and he
wants to be with me so
bad he begs me and begs me and begs me
to leave
the guy that i'm with before i got with
the guy that i'm with now
i was with this guy named jonathan and
he was awesome i just treated him like
[ __ ] and
i left him because i started cheating on
him his friend
which i ended up getting engaged in a
queue it was around his
mertese that's who i got pregnant by
and i had the whole time i was pregnant
i was smoking fentanyl and
smoking crack
so when i had the baby i didn't even
hold him
i was going to but i was so exhausted
from the labor i fell asleep
and then i invaded i was getting woken
up dcf came in
pretty much told me i wasn't leaving
with the baby which i already knew that
before i even got there
the whole pregnancy i had no emotional
attachment to him because i knew i
wasn't gonna have him
i didn't even know if it was a boy or
girl and so he came out
and when i saw him he was so cute
everything all my feelings changed
i wanted to keep him
but i knew i couldn't i didn't even name
him
i don't even know where he is right now
i supposed to go to court on the 30th
and i didn't go
pretty much because i know nothing's
going to change until i do
and he deserves a better life than to be
with me
and i already have two kids that are
left and abandoned i don't deserve
another one
and i shouldn't put another child
through that
so right now i just act like it didn't
even happen really
it's like i wasn't even pregnant
it's like i have no feeling towards it
at all i mean i do but i don't
every day someone said where's the baby
do you have the baby where is he
i was so sick of that question
do you feel like
the path that your childhood put you on
is
fixable can you can you behave
differently can you
can you make good decisions oh yeah i
could if i wanted to
or if i tried to
[Music]
what stops you i think
i'm afraid to [ __ ] it all up
my daughter she's just turned 12.
she's got her period and all this [ __ ]
she's starting to date boys
and i'm afraid if i go i've disappointed
her so much
i'm afraid to go home and try to do it
all over again just to [ __ ] it all up
again
which is dumb because i'm just [ __ ]
up even more just by staying here
what emotions do you deal with most
a lot most of the time i'm depressed as
soon as i had the baby
everyone's like oh my god you're so
skinny you're so skinny you can start
eating
i'm like i eat i'm just so depressed
that i can't even keep weight on
as soon as the baby came out it's like i
deflated
because i was huge they say he was only
seven pounds in a quarter hours but
they're lying
i heard the nurse say nine nine that was
the biggest baby i've ever had
and he was so long he was adorable
i was gonna name him carter anthony
but when i woke up the next morning
after dcf told me that i wasn't leaving
with him
i just got up and left the hospital and
just left and acted like he didn't exist
he's better off where he is mature
than to be with me i'm gonna live in
attendance i think so what i'm gonna do
with a kid
living in a tent with a dog and two
kittens
and a boyfriend that sells drugs shame's
got to be a big part of your
life now right
i'm so disappointed with myself which
leads to getting high to
feel better right it doesn't even make
me feel better i just feel worse after
looking back at your life what do you
wish had been different
i wish i never snorted that pill i wish
i never met will and started with
drinking and doing pills even more
you feel like you're a product of the
environment the childhood environment
that you
not really because no one in my family
really does drugs i'm the only one that
turned out to be a junkie
i mean they smoke weed and drink every
once in a while but no one does hardcore
jokes like i did
i mean i guess go big or go home is what
i said
your dad was a drinker yeah
he wasn't really in my life much the
only thing i remember about him was
going to his house and
him bitching at me i was chewing chips
too loud was one incident or
i asked him to borrow ten dollars and he
told me i owed it to him i had to pay
him back
when that's the only thing i can ever
remember him giving me
as an adult at least
my stepmother did more for us than he
did like she bought the presents
just put his name on him
he does everything for timmy though got
him in racecar i put him in racing
anything jimmy wants to get i guess
that's the way it is with me my mom too
she gave me everything i ever wanted she
never really told me no
i never got grounded different she told
me i was grounded i just begged to go
somewhere and she got sick of listening
to me and told me to do whatever i want
so grounding me just lasted all of an
hour if that
which is a lot of the reason why i am i
am because i got everything i wanted
and my mom was doing the same thing with
my daughter she spoils her to
like she never tells her no she'll hold
her plate up and go mama i'm done
my mom will go get it and put it in the
sink but my son says that she's like get
off your ass and go take care of it
when he's two and she's 10.
how old you know 30.
do you have hope for your future yes
i mean i want to be the mother i should
be that my kids deserve to have
i want the white picket fence and the
happy family
i don't see it happening anytime soon
i guess a big part of me doesn't want to
change
even though i know i should for some
reason i can't see myself giving him
drugs
which is sad
what do you what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
i have no idea
i mean everything happens for a reason i
guess
what reason it is that i'm put in a
situation i don't know besides my own
selfishness
my mom needs to tell me god never gives
you anything more than you can handle
well i can't handle it anymore
my biggest fear is i'm going to end up
dead
or that my mom's going to die before i
see her again
and then what happens to my daughter
that's not enough to make me stop which
is ridiculous
thank you
i mean even when i was trying to change
and everything like that my mom never
said she was proud of me
so why bother trying if it's not going
to be acknowledged
at least she wants me to be a parent but
when i try to parent my daughter
if i tell her no she can have ice cream
before she goes to bed my mom will give
it to her when i'm not looking
so she contradicts everything i say
because she wants to be
the perfect mama
she doesn't want to give me my daughter
back i know she doesn't
she likes that check that she gets she
even told me one day i want you to sign
your rates over because that's more
money i'll get so she's pretty much just
using my daughter as a check
and i mean i know she loves my daughter
absolutely loves her she loves her a
little too much
but i know she sees dollar signs when
she looks at her too
do your friends no i wouldn't call them
friends
more like associates one of my good
friends just overdosed and died the
other day
so i can't go over there and vent to him
anymore because he's not there a lot of
people dying on fentanyl
yeah they say somebody gave him a hot
shot
which i don't know how because he was
very careful about what he did he didn't
do fentanyl he did
black or heroin or whatever you know it
has
and i feel like i can't even talk to the
person that i'm dating because
everything i say or everything i do i'm
[ __ ] somebody else
because i cheated on him once and i told
him about it
and now i can't leave the house or do
anything without being accused of
something
yeah life is pretty hectic for me right
now
i'm pretty close to my breaking point
does it feel better to talk about it yes
i mean i'd like to talk to my
significant other about it but i've
expressed to him that my father wasn't
there
and how much of an angry person he was
and
one day he's like you're just like your
father like how can you say that
my father wasn't even there for one you
don't even know him and i'm nothing like
him at all
like i don't think i am but then again
i'm selfish
he is too i guess i don't want to
believe that i'm like him is more like
it
because he's everything that i don't
want and father
my stepfather was a great stepfather
until he tried to have sex with me
that just ruined everything
[Music]
but yeah one day at a time
all right tiffany thank you so much for
for talking to me
you're welcome
you